[Music]
and but wine metal-y submitted by humans
of California Huk Los Angeles deputy oh
[ __ ] that was a little wrong I know I
was gonna go Phillies but then I turn
around anyway an LA deputy is now under
investigation after faking being shot
why I haven't heard it for a while
anyway
I wonder if my friend knows him damn a
deputy yeah cuz I'm like who the hell is
hands no no like oh well my friend girl
our friend is in this department someone
in the same wo just like just part of
the sheriff all Sheriff's are called
deputies except for the cheap sheriff
there's only one sheriff which is like
it's like saying the Chief of Police and
then everyone else is a deputy so then
what's the difference between chief of
police and uh sure well they're
different agencies so there's like army
marine there's police and then there's
Sheriff
but they're all cops all law enforcement
I tell me this story because I want to
know okay so this sheriff's deputy
falsely claimed that he was shot by a
sniper at the Lancaster sheriff's
station
that's where you [ __ ] up a sniper I
know did he shoot himself so he said
that he got shot from this like building
that's overlooking the sheriff's
departments parking lot
oh and that building they have residents
that have like they suffer from mental
illness oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
yeah so because of all this or they're
trying to look into like how can we even
though it didn't happen but but before
they found the truth yeah oh my god I
will show you a quick video of when the
deputy called in the shot I hope this
will got fired I'm scared
he's probably tough I bet you was his
mistress that shot him kidding he
actually didn't even get shot so it
turns out that he created the holes with
a knife and because it's electric yeah
right now so am i doing consistent with
his story and the fact that like the
hole was too big to what he never worked
with forensic science and that's what I
was gonna say they could tell like where
you're being shot from one oh he's a new
cop idiot he's brand new yeah yeah so
you claim that he was shot or struck in
the chest at about 250 p.m. and when he
was walking to his car in the employee
parking lot and that's when
investigators believe that his
bulletproof vest had saved his life and
so that the bullet just grazed his
shoulder and that's when they ended up
going to this insane manhunt trying to
find this horse well I guess he bored or
what the [ __ ] we don't know why that's
what the thing is called but why because
oh no one knows he doesn't have a why he
just did I see mentality what if he's
just from the mental health place and
you put on it deputy
they're saying that detectives said okay
so he had no visible injuries but he was
still taken to the hospital for
treatment which is weird
oh yeah cuz they have to check yeah make
sure everything so yeah so then
investigators and his colleagues became
suspicious of his story they're like you
know this is kind of weird they were
even saying that the the radio call
about the incident was too calm
so it was like that's kind of weird the
whole like I mentioned the hole in his
shirt was too big for the wound that he
claimed that he had suffered and so by
9:30 p.m.
he was already and under heavy suspicion
even though they were already like
searching for this dude but then
eventually they did halt the search what
a waste of tax dollars and helicopter
fuel yeah I hope he got thrown in jail
your irony when you're gonna go in
through the police department they do so
many tests to make sure you're like
equipped to be a police officer and take
care of people like hardest not enough
they don't do enough I don't think so me
he wanted to go to jail but imagine
doing all that work running for six
months and then just being like oh yeah
they should let a dog bite them you know
they get all these poor little dogs that
these canines they're out there running
the little furry asses off and they're
searching for this non criminal that it
doesn't even exist they should let them
all get a chance to buy them like I
didn't find anything cute on the line
yeah they'll get the dog I ran three
miles for you I didn't see anything
another one goes bites my god they get a
tree after always having it's his left
nut yeah oh yeah they even had SWAT team
and armor you surrounding an area and
then they blocked off that apartment
building that I mentioned that overlooks
if I was trying I'd be [ __ ] pissed
too because imagine right cuz those guys
as soon as they get the call your
adrenaline is I yeah right and they're
rolling up in that armored vehicle
everyone's like [ __ ] there's a [ __ ]
guy somewhere up here someone's gonna
get shot today
yeah especially after what happened in
Dallas yeah everyone's on high alert
yeah and did they charge into that is it
a mental hospital or what is the
apartment building damn can you imagine
like if you already suffering with all
these like different Anakin
yeah people you got the whole SWAT team
were coming in busting down doors and
[ __ ] but like I just want to know what
the [ __ ] this got like she just got off
of lunching he was like huh right let's
make it up I just got shot like what is
failed to provide an explanation for his
motive for fabricating the story she
should I got to pay some sort of fee or
something for wasting so much money I'm
getting charged for fault of filing a
false claim you know you know what I
think happened I think there's a there's
a conspiracy behind all of this
I think he was forced to do it you too
much grace appearance because there's no
reason oh by the by the by the law
reason the sheriff Overlord he was like
you got to do this and you got to take
the rap because we need a we need a we
need a Coria we need to start some [ __ ]
right now to divert the attention to go
somewhere else there's more training
they she totally had that same thought
when I was reading this story it's a
conspiracy I was having the same thought
because he can't come up with a
reasonable explanation why he did this
and he wasted so much so many resources
so much time cuz it took hours so he's
just a distraction for some other shitty
martyr so like while these officers were
out looking for the perpetrator like
someone was sneaking into the evidence
room or something like that what you
guys think there's some real [ __ ]
because all of the [ __ ] department
had to go out because they're like this
is right this is red alert because
anytime like for a cop if a cop is
getting shot at they get extra motivated
cuz it's not just like a regular person
we're gonna shoot at us so they go with
full Calvary ready to [ __ ] knock
sitting down yeah that's crazy but yeah
that building nothing so it's used by a
nonprofit organization to house people
with mental illness Oh or maybe there
was something in that building that they
wanted to get oh and that's where they
went in there
well the only police officers could just
walk in it anywhere and take whatever
they have a probable cause or a warrant
see but then if they did that they would
have covered their own way better they
would have been like you he's not shot
at or what if it's like Ocean's eleven
remember when they called the SWAT team
and then I get on my head man I totally
thought about the Ocean's eleven through
with the SWAT Cardo in the other movie
that did that so like okay that's fine
Mexican music
Vanja she just wants to connect with you
yet I know but I don't I want to cut
that connection
roasted dip Joe the LaRose
she's like next level patreon to watch
the roast of tiff it was a typical roast
episode it's like Jeffrey Ross for us
yeah TIFF Belarus the best names now
that was a good one dude tricking me ya
know they're smart I want a name can you
give me a name and you can't use [ __ ]
that one's heard about you remember when
we first first met and I called you I
would comment on your pictures on my
gusto gorgey OS no that's cute it's
gotta be offensive yeah yeah yeah fifty
LaRose kind of Bobby yeah one of those
kind of like a playboy yeah yeah those
are good oh you don't like puns oh when
you do it
huh I like when they're funny but anyway
I know dude this guy so we never found
out why wasted summon there's so many
shootings and [ __ ] that honestly when I
see the person that was the shooter I'm
like bro there's some weird conspiracy
happening right now where I feel like I
don't know man like there are white
there have you seen the pictures they
all look the same
but then there's this Mexican cook and
[ __ ] and I'm like dude did they like pay
you money for your family and you're
like the martyr now like it's just so I
think sometimes that could work that way
it's so weird to me right now like the
guy that shot Kennedy or whatever people
say that like that was a he was like
paid to be the fall guy yeah yeah it's
just I have just up weird vibe right now
there's a lot of like just conspiracy
[ __ ] going on that just stop it's done
you know the FBI moved to it like close
that case yeah did I dismiss it right
it's like what nobody else wants to die
well the the ladies the accusers of
Epstein just they got to say there and
it's done yeah but then that's just them
saying stuff out you already know that
that went to someone else's hands like
okay he died so now someone say okay for
sure she killed him don't she has so
much money she could get so much face
surgery and he could just live as a
little life you know his mamas on the
the mrs. gazelle they there's a picture
of her at [ __ ] in and out just
recently someone took a picture of her
here in LA
why was she supposed to be in prison no
but they're like why she's why is she
not being sued going for hiding like why
is she not being caught and questioned
why she didn't [ __ ] in and out if
she's because she's hungry from all the
running you know like and that's pretty
good it's crazy this is unfolding right
in front of our [ __ ] eyes you can't
do [ __ ] yeah so I feel about everything
in the news I'm like well I can't do
anything about it like I can't get angry
but I can't do anything about it and
maybe that's why there's so many people
like protesting about everything I know
and then Kelly's like trying to do some
day have such a big heart
because honestly it's so exhausting to
me sometimes where I'm like I just can
[ __ ] like I believe in here like
everybody go like that we can vote and
that's about it yeah I mean what are you
voting for cuz it's the [ __ ] what
you're voting for there's like
paragraphs and pages yeah [ __ ] worse
for you to educate your snot I don't
understand how that [ __ ]
I'm just I'm gonna vote I'm just Christ
in Spanish I don't know what else to do
you're just gonna waste out right yeah
you can hold a class for us all yeah
teach us what we could do a video in the
answers I just do I just like you can go
get like cliff notes off of like what
each proposition means and like but is
it a biased cliff no no no like you can
find out like just like hey this one's
saying this and this one's saying that
one Nick you said check Nikki
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]